liebe kolleginnen und kollegen herzlich
willkommen in der bundespressekonferenz
herzlich willkommen unseren gästen den
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn und
herrn professor lothar wieler dem
präsident des robert koch institutes
es geht um die aktuelle corona lage für
alle die uns an den bildschirmen
verfolgen dies ist eine
bundespressekonferenz in der
bundespressekonferenz und
journalistinnen und journalisten
organisiert die über die bundespolitik
und über die bundesregierung berichten
und wir bemühen uns dass hier möglichst
viele fragen gestellt und auf möglichst
viele fragen beantwortet werden unter
der regie von journalisten
vielen dank also und wir laden die
mitglieder der bundesregierung zu uns
als gäste ein und freuen uns auch dass
sie kommen in diesen zeiten lassen wir
live übertragungen zu und mein
herzlicher dank gilt dem sender findungs
der uns hier mit der
gebärdendolmetscherin unterstützt das
können sie auch phönix seen aber auch
nur auf phoenix es geht um die aktuelle
grundlage das habe ich schon gesagt herr
minister sie haben das wort heute morgen
meldet das robert-koch-institut über
25.000 neue corona fälle das sind um es
ganz deutlich zu sagen zu viele zu viele
menschen die jeden tag sich infizieren
die sich die erkrankten zu viele die in
ein paar tagen ins krankenhaus müssen so
viele die bald auch um ihr leben ringen
werden müssen
und wenn es so weitergeht sind es zu
viele
für unser gesundheitssystem hinzu kommt
die zahlen die wir heute sehen spiegeln
höchstwahrscheinlich nicht das wahre
infektionsgeschehen wieder denn über die
feiertage dürften weniger menschen zum
arzt gegangen sein und sich testen zu
lassen
daher sollten die aktuell relativ
niedrigen zahlen unser handeln nicht
leiten
denn in unseren krankenhäusern zeigt
sich wie ernst die situation tatsächlich
ist die zahl der kurve 19
intensivpatienten steigt viel zu schnell
sie liegt bereits wieder bei fast 4500
intensiv patienten in deutschen kliniken
die ärztinnen und ärzte die pflegekräfte
schlagen zurecht alarm sie sind
seit vielen monaten unter dauerstress
wir dürfen nicht warten bis die kliniken
überlastet sind
das gilt jetzt mit b1 17 als auch
ansteckende variante um so mehr darum
müssen wir diese dritte welle brechen
und zwar möglichst rasch das heißt
kontakte reduzieren und mobilität
runterfahren
nur so verhindern wir weiter steigende
fallzahlen und das ist mir besonders
wichtig nur so schützen wir unser
gesundheitssystem vor überlastung ganz
konkret geht es dabei um drei bereiche
und private treffen kontakte am
arbeitsplatz und schulen und kitas schul
und kita kinder müssen mindestens
zweimal die woche getestet werden und
getestet werden können dazu haben sich
im übrigen die länder vor einem monat
selbst verpflichtet die home office
pflicht muss stärker eingefordert werden
und auch in den betrieben müssen wir
dahin kommen dass zweimal die woche ist
zum betriebsalltag gehört ganz
selbstverständlich auch getestet zu
werden und private kontakte kontakte
sollten wir so gut es geht einschränken
wenn nötig so schwer das feld wenn nötig
auch durch nächtliche
ausgangsbedingungen denn die frage ist
ja eher der weg zum sich ab mit einander
treffen und ich kenne das ja ich komme
ja nur selbst auch von einem dorf im
zweifel denkt man sich nach den nachbarn
kenne ich gut und lange da werde ich
mich schon nicht anstecken
so ist es aber meistens nicht der machen
im zweifel weiß auch der nachbar gar
nicht dass er vielleicht symptomlos
infiziert ist und dann sitzen alle in
einem raum beieinander und dann auch
wenn sich alle gut kennen kann dieses
virus überspringen
deswegen ist es wichtig gerade diesen
bereich in den blick zu nehmen
das fällt niemandem leicht aber es ist
notwendig um diese zahlen zu senken
braucht es konsequente und möglichst
bundeseinheitliche maßnahmen meines
erachtens wäre eine bund länder runde
eigentlich das richtige format dafür
aber wenn manche schon die einschätzung
der lage nicht teilen
dann wird es natürlich schwierig eine
kurze rücksprache reicht jedenfalls
angesichts der lage nicht ich kann mich
über manche äußerungen dieser tage nur
wundern
ich empfehle uns allen den
parteienstreit war ja hin oder her
runter zu fahren und uns auf das
wesentliche zu konzentrieren die
bekämpfung der pandemie und hier müssen
wir übrigens egal ob bundesgesetz oder
ministerpräsidenten konferenzen alle an
einem strang ziehen
das erwartet die große mehrheit der
bürgerinnen und bürger von uns und viele
bürgerinnen und bürger erkennen auch die
notwendigkeit diese welle mit
zusätzlichen maßnahmen zu brechen
das zeigen uns viele umfragen sehr klar
die bürgerinnen und bürger jedenfalls
schätzen die lage und den ernst der lage
realistisch ein und befürworten
mehrheitlich strengere regeln es braucht
einen lock down um die aktuelle welle zu
brechen und dauerhaft und stabil unter
100 deutlich unter 100 idealerweise bei
der incidents zu kommen
das kann eine brücke bauen in eine phase
um dann test gestützt mehr zu öffnen
auch mehr als feuer im einzelhandel in
der außengastronomie bei fußballspielen
aber die reihenfolge ist wichtig er ist
deutlich unter 100 um dann test gestützt
zu öffnen um dann auch mit dem impfen im
sommer den entscheidenden unterschied zu
machen denn wir haben die werkzeuge hier
an der hand um die fall und todeszahlen
zu senken
die beschränkung von kontakten und
mobilität die erhöhung der impfzahlen
und der test zahlen den ausbau der
kapazitäten im zusammenspiel liegt der
schlüssel das eine ersetzt nicht das
andere beim impfen sind wir auf einem
guten weg in den vergangenen tagen und
so viele menschen geimpft wie nie zuvor
denn seit dieser woche sind erstens mehr
impfstoffe verfügbar und zweitens impfen
die hausärztinnen und ärzte mit
zu den 450 impfzentren der länder sind
so 35.000 kleinere aber sehr
ineffiziente impfzentren dazugekommen
die arztpraxen und es werden noch mehr
werden
mittlerweile wurden 17 millionen dosen
in deutschland verhilft 12,2 millionen
erstimpfung 14,7 prozent der deutschen
haben eine erste impfung also fast 15
prozent der deutschen mindestens eine
impfung
fast 6 prozent in vollständigen schutz
nach zweitimpfung wir haben gestern
einen weiteren tagesrekord bei den
impfungen von 719 1000 impfungen an
einem tag 325.000 in den praxen und auch
das sei erwähnt einen neuen rekord auch
in den impfzentren von fast 400.000
impfungen
wir sehen also mit den gestiegenen
lieferzahlen steigen jetzt auch die
impfzahlen und wir können tatsächlich
dort eine positive entwicklung sehen ich
will aber auch gleich dazu sagen es wird
jetzt nicht jeden tag einen neuen rekord
geben können sondern wir werden jetzt
natürlich sehen weil wir momentan die
arztpraxen jahr mit einer million dosen
pro woche
diese nächste und übernächste woche
beliefern werden pro woche eine million
dosen dass wir dann natürlich nicht
jeden tag diese größenordnung sehen
werden aber es wird jetzt eben immer
weiter aufwachsen können und im mai dann
auch bei den arztpraxen deutlich mehr
noch geimpft werden können
deswegen ist es eben wichtig dass der
impfstoff der da ist schnellstmöglich
verimpft in den impfzentren aber auch in
den arztpraxen grad an den arztpraxen
wissen wir was anfang der woche
geliefert wird es bis ende der woche
tatsächlich auch verimpft
die vergangenen tage haben im übrigen
auch gezeigt wie groß das interesse an
allen drei verfügbaren impfstoffen ist
dort wo es ein angebot auch für über 60
jährige gab wurde es auch angenommen
das habe ich daheim in nordrhein
westfalen auch erlebt wo die termine ja
sehr schnell vergeben waren und wir
werden übrigens dem bundestag impfdosen
von astrazeneca zur verfügung stellen um
ab nächster woche auch die über 60
jährigen kollegen und kollegen im
deutschen bundestag kämpfen zu können
durch die parlaments- ärztin und es gibt
noch eine gute nachricht das robert koch
institut ist zu dem schluss gekommen
dass das risiko dass vollständig
geimpfte das virus weiter geben noch
geringer ist als bei negativ getesteten
das heißt wir können jeden der die
zweite dosis erhalten hat zwei wochen
später so behandeln als hätte er gerade
aktuell einen negativen test gemacht und
das noch mal deutlich zu sagen das ist
kein privileg oder sonderrecht
jeder kann sich
kostenlos testen lassen wenn wir aktuell
getestete und vollständig geimpfte bei
der frage etwa einer flugreise oder
sonstigen test erfordernissen etwa im
einzelhandel wie sie perspektivisch
ergeben wird gleichstellen
dann hat jeder die möglichkeit zu
gleichen zugängen weil jeder sich
kostenlos testen lassen kann
und selbstverständlich und das ist sehr
sehr wichtig gelten sowohl für
tagesaktuell getestete wie für
vollständig geimpfte abstands und
hygieneregeln weiterhin mit den
gesundheitsministern und ministern der
länder habe ich diese woche besprochen
dass wir unsere verordnungen und
empfehlungen den neuen erkenntnissen
anpassen das heißt beim reisen kann die
testpflicht für vollständig geimpfte
weitgehend entfallen nur wer aus einem
virus varianten gebiet zurückkehrt muss
sich dann weiterhin testen lassen das
werden wir im laufe des aprils umsätzen
genauso wie die entsprechenden
quarantäne regel anpassungen
kontaktpersonen von infizierten müssen
in der regel nicht mehr in quarantäne
wenn sie bereits mehr als zwei wochen
vollständig geimpft sind und keine
symptome haben
das robert-koch-institut hat diese
empfehlung bereits angepasst
zusammengefasst das sind jetzt noch mal
schwere wochen mit ernsten und auch
schwerwiegenden entscheidungen für viele
bürgerinnen und bürger
umso mehr ist ein entschlossenes und vor
allem ein gemeinsames handeln wichtig es
geht darum unser gesundheitssystem nicht
zu überlasten
es geht darum menschenleben zu schützen
und es geht auch darum gesundheit zu
schützen
denn der blick auf die täglichen
todeszahlen die gemeldet werden ist das
eine ist ein wichtiger aber wir dürfen
nicht vergessen dass durch ko wird 19
auch longo witt viele erkrankten und
auch dort viel leid entsteht es geht
darum diese dritte welle zu brechen und
dann mit kleineren kontakte mobilitäts
beschränkungen testen und impfen eine
perspektive zu geben
morgen meine damen und herren wir
befinden uns in der dritten welle
ausgelöst durch die variante b 11 7
diese ist noch ansteckender sie ist noch
gefährlicher und daher auch nur schwer
einzudämmen
daran hat sich de facto in den letzten
auch nichts geändert glücklicherweise
aber werden immer mehr menschen geimpft
aber sucht natürlich noch dauern bis die
impfungen einen effekt auf der
bevölkerungs ebene zeigen wir können
diese welle nicht mehr verhindern aber
meine hoffnung ist dass sie zumindest
abflachen können um die folgen
abzumildern
das schaffen wir aber nur gemeinsam jede
infektion die wir gemeinsam verhindern
ist ein erfolg meine damen und herren
die fallzahlen und auch die sieben tages
inzidenz sind im moment nicht so
zuverlässig wie wir es gerne hätten dass
herr liegt hauptsächlich daran weil über
die feiertage und auch die osterferien
weniger arztbesuche stattfanden und
entsprechend auch weniger getestet wurde
aber wir gehen davon aus dass wir wieder
verlässlichere zahlen haben ab mitte der
nächsten woche
meine damen herren das bedeutet aber
nicht dass wir nicht wissen wo wir uns
befinden und wie die situation aussieht
nein das gegenteil ist der fall wir
betrachten immer und das von anfang an
verschiedene faktoren und viele
verschiedene faktoren um die innovation
situation einzuschätzen
und ganz entscheidend ist hier die
entwicklung in den krankenhäusern
denn dort werden ja jene mitmenschen
behandelt die am schwersten an cupid 19
erkranken und diese entwicklung zeigt
leider dass die lage sehr sehr ernst ist
wenn wir uns etwa die daten aus der
krankenhaus lienz anschauen
das robert-koch-institut dann sehen wir
dass immer mehr menschen mit schweren
atemwegsinfektionen wegen cupid 19 im
krankenhaus behandelt werden müssen und
die betroffenen werden auch immer jünger
gerade bei den 35 bis 49 jährigen und
den 60 bis 79 jährigen sind diese zahlen
seit mitte märz stark gestiegen bei den
15 bis 34 jährigen gab es ebenfalls
wieder mehr kogit 19 fälle im
krankenhaus auch wenn es auf einem
deutlich geringeren niveau ist als bei
den älteren
bei den über 80-jährigen da hat sich die
zahl glücklicherweise stabilisiert das
ist sicher auch auf die impfungen zurück
zu
die eben wirken auch der
altersdurchschnitt der mit menschen die
auf den intensivstationen behandelt
werden müssen sinkt mitte bis ende märz
lage zwischen 65 und 68 jahren und am
anfang des jahres lag der
altersdurchschnitt zwischen 170 und 77
jahren
diese zahlen beziehen sich auf etwas
mehr als 70 krankenhäuser in fast allen
regionen in deutschland die an der
robert koch institut kartenhaus events
teilnehmen und wir gehen davon aus dass
sie die situation in ganz deutschland
ganz gut widerspiegeln
auch die daten aus dem intensiv register
wir stehen ja alle auf unserer website
transparent sind sehr besorgniserregend
die intensivstation füllen sich rasant
und zwar in fast allen bundesländern
zurzeit werden annähernd 4519
patientinnen und patienten auf
intensivstationen in deutschland
behandelt alleine der letzten woche
meine damen und herren sind 700
patienten hinzu gekommen das entspricht
einem zuwachs von 20 prozent innerhalb
einer woche
85 prozent der kogit 19 patientinnen
müssen beatmet werden etwa zwei drittel
der intensiv bereiche sind nach eigenen
angaben bereits begrenzt oder
ausgelastet und was die situation
verschärft ist die tatsache dass die
belegung der intensivstationen noch bei
2.700 patienten von der zweiten welle
lag die patienten aus der dritten welle
kommen also noch dazu und mit
zeitverzögerung werden natürlich noch
mehr dazukommen
es ist leider absehbar dass die kranken
heute und intensivstationen in den
kommenden wochen massiv belastet sein
werden und auch im hinblick darauf dass
jüngere patienten länger auf
intensivstationen bleiben als ältere
und ich möchte ja auch nochmals ganz
deutlich klar machen es geht hier nicht
nur darum dass geräte oder betten
ausgelastet sind nein sondern auch die
menschen die dort ihre pflicht tun tag
und nacht seit vielen monaten
die sind überlastet jetzt pflegepersonal
krankenschwestern wir alle meine damen
und herren wir alle haben die pflicht
das zu verhindern
für alle brauchen ein funktionierendes
gesundheitssystem und jeder von uns und
jeder der uns wichtiges kann plötzlich
krank werden oder einen unfall haben und
möchte dann natürlich bestmöglich
versorgt werden
wenn kliniken durch ko wird 19
überlastet sind dann ist diese
versorgung gefährdet deshalb bitte
schützen sie sich und schützen wir uns
alle vor infektionen mit dem sauerstoff
2 virus
je weniger menschen überhaupt erst krank
werden desto weniger muss ins
krankenhaus des und desto weniger
menschen erleiden auch spätfolgen das
sogenannte longo witt wir müssen daher
dafür weiter konsequent alle werkzeuge
einsetzen die uns zur verfügung stehen
die basis bleibt also die reduktion von
kontakten die abstandsregeln das tragen
von mund nasenschutz hygieneregeln und
natürlich in innenräumen vor allem das
lüften
wegen der erosion entstehung und dazu
kommen eben zusätzlich dann noch die
anderen werkzeuge das sind die tests und
die impfung und wenn sie symptome einer
atemwegsinfektion haben bitte bleiben
sie zu hause rufen sie einen arzt an und
lasse nicht dann mit pcr testen das ist
immer noch der sicherste weg einer
gezielten diagnose man da und kann ich
weiß dass sehr viele menschen diese
regeln beherzigen und sich sehr
verantwortungsvoll verhalten und dafür
kann ich mich nur immer und immer wieder
herzlich bedanken
in einigen regionen wird aktuell bei 7
tages instanzen um 100 gelockert im
hinblick auf die eben beschriebene
situation in unseren krankenhäusern
intensivstationen ist das bedenklich
zumindest solange wirksame zusätzlich
konzepte der pandemie eindämmung fehlen
denken sie daran unter diesen umständen
bedeuten lockerungen nicht dass die
menschen nun einem niedrigeren
infektionsrisiko ausgesetzt sind es
bedeutet vielmehr dass die
verantwortungsträger die verantwortung
der panini bewältigen
auf die einzelnen abgeben umso wichtiger
ist es dass wir uns alle schützen
ich bin sehr froh darüber dass sich
viele menschen impfen lassen möchten
auch mit dem impfstoff von astrazeneca
seit einer woche sehen wir ja einen
kontinuierlichen anstieg der asta
weniger impfung bei den 60 bis 70
jährigen insbesondere über ostern zum
beispiel am sich zehntausende von der
altersgruppe impfen lassen
auch ich hatte die gelegenheit dazu und
darüber bin ich sehr dankbar
das muss ich ganz klar sagen das ist ja
der schritt zur kontrolle der pandemie
das für eine immunität aufbauen
darum kann ich nur wiederholen wenn sie
eine impfung angeboten bekommen bitte
nehmen sie sie sich auch an die impfung
sind es die uns den weg aus der pandemie
zeigen die impfungen und der schutz für
infektion nur über immunität und
prävention schutz vor infektionen können
wir somit 19 kontrollieren vielen dank
herr professor wieland mir liegen jetzt
schon mehr als 20 fragen zuvor was sehr
viel ist mit blick auf unsere zielmarke
11 uhr ende der pressekonferenz die
erste frage ist bei herrn rinke und ich
bin mir nicht sicher ob ich in diesem
segment des saales schon alle
aufgenommen habe sie habe ich nämlich
nicht und ok wunderbar habe ich habe ich
habe ich erinner hat das wort
ja das problem beschäftigt uns schon
seit einigen tagen weil wir die meldung
bekommen wir haben gleichwohl die
verordnung ja angepasst von einer
quartalsmäßigen abschlagszahlung zu
einer monatlichen genau um dieses thema
zu adressieren weil natürlich kommunale
testzentren oder testzentren der
kassenärztlichen vereinigung im zweifel
diese vorfinanzierung machen können da
wo im auftrag der behörden vor ort
private anbieter zum teil haben ja auch
eventveranstalter gastronomen
entsprechende test angebote entwickelt
vor ort das machen ist wichtig dass
monatlich bezahlt wird es wird er jetzt
für den märz die erste abschlagszahlung
in der nächsten oder die erste bezahlung
nicht ab schon in der nächsten woche
geben und es besteht auch die
möglichkeit von abschlagszahlungen das
wird in vielen kassenärztlichen
vereinigungen die die abrechnungen ja
auch machen auch genutzt also problem
ist nicht nur bekannt sondern aus
unserer sicht auch schon mit vielen
lösungen es maßnahmen adressiert und da
wo weiter ein themen sind schauen wir
uns das natürlich noch mal an wir wollen
die test infrastruktur unbedingt
erhalten und behalten weil wenn wir
diese welle gebrochen haben sollten
besser früher als später dann brauchen
wir natürlich die test infrastruktur
dann für das test gestützte öffnen und
dann übrigens wird auch deutlich mehr
tests geben noch mehr weil dann ja ist
sozusagen mit dem testen auch
möglichkeiten gibt jenseits des sich
selbstsicher sein über die situation
dann greife ich hier eine frage von
außen und gleichauf zum thema selbst
test fragt von charlotte kurz von der
pharmazeutischen zeitung sie herrn
bundesminister sie hatten im februar
angekündigt die preisentwicklung der
korona line test zunächst beobachten zu
wollen ist ihre beobachtung bereits
abgeschlossen und gibt es derzeit
von seiten des bundes die abgabe von
selbst test finanziell zu unterstützen
eine beobachtung ich kann echt zitiere
hier reis ist auch jetzt verantworten
uhr achtung ist nicht abgeschlossen weil
die setzen wir so oder so fort wir
beobachten alles fortwährend schließen
keine beobachtungen ab sondern die frage
ist ja welche schlussfolgerungen wir aus
dem beobachteten ziehen und ob im moment
noch nicht weil wir bei dem selbst
tester setzte wichtige teil die
selbsttests nicht die schnellste ist die
selbsttests im moment ja noch in der
situation sind das vor allem eben die
öffentlichen stellen auch die länder für
die kitas und die schulen beschafft
haben beziehungsweise noch zusätzlich
für den jahresverlauf beschaffen und das
jetzt erstmal auch die priorität
übrigens auch der meisten hersteller und
anbieter ist die sind jenseits der
vereinbarung die sie mit uns getroffen
haben auch aus sich heraus sehr daran
interessiert er ist auch einmal diesen
bereich abzudecken jetzt an dieser
stelle ist aus meiner sicht zu früh
angesichts der marktlage noch weitere
schritte zu gehen jetzt das kann in zwei
oder vier wochen natürlich schon anders
sein sie sehen jede woche zusätzliche
tests übrigens die zugelassen werden es
befand wir sind mittlerweile schon über
30 wenn ich es richtig im kopf habe
tests kommen jede woche zusätzliche
tests zugelassen werden werden übrigens
auch schon tests gehabt die durch die
qualitätsanforderungen durchgefallen
sind
es macht durchaus sinn sich die qualität
anzuschauen jetzt geht es weiter bei ihm
können sie netterweise ins mikro
sprechen und sie besser zu verstehen
also wir erhalten tatsächlich eigentlich
zu allen impfstoffen die es auf der welt
gibt auch auf allen ebenen es kommen wir
dann auch kollegen auf uns zu
entsprechende angebote von
zwischenhändlern die unternehmen in
aller regel beliefern nur starten
stand jetzt deswegen nehmen wir sofort
kontakt auf zu den unternehmen wir
informieren die kommission es wird in
manchen fällen auch interpol informiert
weil es ja um die frage geht das ist ein
bisschen wie eigentlich in dieser
pandemie immer wieder mit verschiedenen
produkten es entsteht dann so eine
goldgräberstimmung an verschiedenen
bereichen
dann wird versucht mit angeboten aller
art was zu machen wir als bund
jedenfalls beschaffen bei den
herstellern und ausschließlich dort und
bis jetzt haben sich die meisten
angebote wo wir überhaupt mal im
einzelfall wir können da tatsächlich
jetzt nicht immer jedem nachgehen
sondern wir informieren die hersteller
wir informieren die kommission wir
informieren über die kommission
informiert möglicherweise noch
ermittlungsbehörden wir bestellen bei
den herstellern
grundsätzlich sind in europa in der
europäischen union verkehrs fähige
impfstoffe erstmal verkehrsfähig die
frage des der einführung von impfstoffen
unterliegt dem geltenden
arzneimittelrecht es braucht für
bestimmte bereiche einfach erlaubnisse
zu durch die zuständigen landesbehörden
nach dem arzneimittelrecht und es muss
die eu zulassung umfasst im übrigen auch
die herstellungs- städten also es kann
nicht aus jeder herstellung städte auf
der welt wie möglicherweise ein in der
eu zugelassene impfstoff produziert
worden ist einfach nach europa
importiert und genug
werden sondern die herstellungskette
muss erst inspiziert werden durch die
europäische arzneimittelagentur und die
und die nationalen behörden
kooperationen und dann teil der
zulassung werden aber es gibt ja noch
arzneimittelrecht die möglichkeit unter
den bedingungen des arzneimittel rechtes
nach deutschland zu importieren
stichwort impfstoff theresa münch dpa
fragt welche impfstoffe bekommen die
hausärzte in der kommenden woche
bekommen sie mehr astrazeneca ist
zunächst vorgesehen und dafür weniger
biotec also zuerst einmal wenn ich das
noch mal sagen darf angesichts aktueller
diskussionen ich habe hier an dieser
stelle vor gut einer woche gesagt dass
ab mitte april astra zenica in die
arztpraxen geht also keine neue
information sondern eine mindestens eine
woche alte informationen aber manchmal
sind ja informationen auf einmal wieder
neu erlebt man ja gelegentlich
jedenfalls ist es so dass in die
arztpraxen tatsächlich jetzt in den
ersten zwei wochen ausschließlich bei
montech geht diese woche waren es 109
140000 dosen etwa nächste woche sind gut
eine million dosen in der woche darauf
teilt es sich die eine hälfte ist bei
antec die andere hälfte des astra zenica
es ist wieder gut eine million dosen und
dann wird es eben zug um zug mehr werden
und mehr werden können ich will nur eins
sagen wir haben mit bayon tag einen sehr
verlässlichen lieferanten nach den
anfangs vielleicht erinnert sich der
eine oder andere anfang januar gab es ja
produktions themen und umstellungen aber
seitdem sehr verlässlich auch immer was
den wochentag angeht sehr verlässlich
und ich meine dass es frei nur
deskriptive schreiben
bei den anderen herstellern haben wir
diese verlässlichkeit was den liefer tag
und was die liefermenge angeht so noch
nicht erreicht aufgrund scheinbar der
produktionsprozesse das führt dazu dass
manchmal wird die kalenderwoche wissen
aber noch nicht den kalender tag und
wenn dann am ende einer kalenderwoche
eine lieferung kommt kann sie nicht am
anfang der kalenderwoche an die
arztpraxen geliefert werden
das ist das was im moment für uns und
für die ärztinnen und ärzte die
herausforderung ist in der planung
das ist jetzt eine situation die einfach
den produktionsprozessen noch geschuldet
ist und wo wir eben mit den ärztinnen
und ärzten den apothekern den großhandel
mit allen beteiligten im intensiven
kontakt sind und immer dann wenn neue
informationen sind sie auch zu geben wo
die entscheidende information ist ja
dass eben es bei über einer million
impfungen in den arztpraxen pro woche
bleiben kann und diese zahl dann weiter
steigt vor allem mai dann stark steigen
wird
dann nehme ich doch eine frage von
patrick holl stand von apotheke adhoc
dazu der fragt nämlich wie zufrieden sie
mit der auslieferung herr minister sind
des impfstoffes an praxen durch
großhandel und apotheken und wo sie
gegebenenfalls verbesserungsbedarf sehen
und was sind mit den kürzungen in der
übernächsten woche auf sich hat die
kürzung hab ich ja gerade schon das ist
zahlenmäßig keine kürzung unterschiede
weiß mehr als ich offenkundig wir
liefern
es ist es wissen sie es bringt doch nix
ich verstehe die ganze aufregung nicht
sie können ja wir können jetzt jeden tag
im ticker meldung machen werden irgendwo
mal 10.000 dosen nicht ankommen oder
wenn mal 500.000 in der lieferung am
ende der woche kommen statt am anfang
der woche
es ist im moment noch so dass die
impfstoffhersteller 24 7 365 tage im
jahr produzieren ohne lagerhaltung das
heißt dass jedes kleine ereignis dazu
führt wenn nur irgendein produkt von
hunderten von vorprodukten ausfällt oder
einen tag später geliefert wird das sich
etwas verzögert und deswegen ist es
nicht auszuschließen ich will das
ausdrücklich noch einmal sagen dass bei
den zahlen die wir veröffentlichen für
die nächsten kalenderwochen ist zu
veränderungen kommt und zwar nicht weil
der bundesminister für gesundheit
irgendwie auf die idee kommt weniger
ausliefern zu wollen sondern aller regel
liegt es daran dass aufgrund der
produktionsabläufe weniger geliefert
werden kann
wir haben ja in aller regel diese
impfstoffe nicht besonders lange im
bundesbesitz sondern sie gehen direkt so
schnell es geht auch weiter und deswegen
sage ich noch einmal uns die aktuelle
erwartete liefermenge diese
kalenderwoche die s ausgelegt
sicher 940.000 nächste kalenderwoche
eine million 12.000 darauf die
kalenderwoche in etwa die gleiche
größenordnung und dann aber eben ein mix
aus pech und astra zenica und ich
verrate jetzt schon auch johnson &
johnson wird in die arztpraxen gehen wir
haben von anfang an gesagt bei montech
und moderner werden auf dauer die
impfstoffe in den impfzentren sein und
bei montech astra zenica von johnson &
johnson werden die impfstoffe in den
arztpraxen seien und deswegen war von
anfang an klar dass es in den arztpraxen
verschiedene impfstoffhersteller
angebote geben wird das bringt mich zu
der frage wie zufrieden ich bin mit dem
was wir diese woche gesehen haben ich
bin sehr zufrieden damit wie das
gelaufen ist heißt das dass das problem
frei gelaufen ist nein natürlich nicht
wenn sie ein prozess völlig neu für ein
was ist völlig neu völlig neu ist die
bayern tag lieferung ist ja anders als
eine grippe impfstoff lieferung sonntag
braucht nicht nur was die kühlung angeht
sondern auch was die erschütterung oder
nicht erschütterung angeht auf dem
transportweg sehr besondere
voraussetzungen und das ist schon eine
der anspruchsvolleren lieferungen die es
im arzneimittelbereich gibt in die
apotheken und unter denen sozusagen vor
prämissen finde ich ist das sehr sehr
gut gelaufen diese woche es ist nicht so
gelaufen das ist nicht irgendwo auch mal
ein problem gegeben hat es ist nicht so
gelaufen
das nicht auch eine lieferung einige
haben dienstag mit einer lieferung
gerechnet sie kam am mittwoch auch jetzt
nach ostern es ist nicht problemfrei
gelaufen aber es ist strich drunter
angesichts des umstandes dass 35.000
arztpraxen in ganz deutschland mit einem
sehr schwer zu transportieren einem
produkt beliefert worden sind ziemlich
gut gelaufen
ich hoffe dass hier jetzt auch gut läuft
und wie ein bisschen vorankommen
bitteschön bemühe mich umrissen
zuerst habe ich ja gesagt es könnte eine
solche strategie entwickelt werden
leicht mit dem test angebot im
entsprechenden wir sehen ja auch bei der
minister schulminister konferenz gestern
was ich glaube ich wieder vorgestern das
ist auch dort nicht gelungen ist eine
einheitliche linie zu finden
also ich kann halt nur zu einem
zurückkommen für uns ist in dieser phase
der pandemie sehr wichtig vor allem auch
mit blick darauf wenn wir denn dann nach
einem runterfahren und einbrechen der
welle dann wieder öffnen dass wir das
test gestützt tun und dass wir in den
lebenswelten die es gibt
wir haben ja auch sonst in der
präventionspolitik vor allem so 23
lebenswelten da wo man seinen alltag
außerhalb des heimes verbringt das
berufsschule oder für die studentinnen
und studenten die universität dass wir
in diesen lebenswelten idealerweise
mindestens zweimal pro woche testen und
dass das selbstverständlicher lebenswelt
alltag wird also da wo präsenz in den
universitäten ist eine lesung oder oder
seminar was auch immer da wo
präsenzveranstaltungen sind ist aus
meiner sicht ist unbedingt erforderlich
dass wir zu einem entsprechenden test
angebot kommen
also im moment ist für uns alle das was
das leben lebenswert macht nicht möglich
herr professor ich hab auch gerne wieder
feiern und gastronomie und sonst was
aber es geht halt gerade nicht und das
gilt für studentinnen und studenten und
das gilt für uns alle und ansonsten was
die frage angeht ergänzen aber ansonsten
kann ich halt nur empfehlen wenn man
präsenzveranstaltung macht sie durch
testen zu begleiten
gleichwohl ist es glaube ich in
bestimmten altersgruppen leichter auch
digitale angebote zu machen als bei
siebenjährigen herr professor wieland ja
ich möchte es nur ergänzen
also zum das ist ja zum einen die
entscheidung der universitäten selber
dass das wissen wir ja so aber ich
konkret ich kenne ein projekt ich kenne
auch nicht viele projekte aber ich kenne
ein projekt das momentan gefahren wird
das ist in dortmund an der universität
dort gibt es einen test zur konzept das
ausgerollt wird das jetzt überprüft wird
dort arbeitet man zb mit pcr tests
zweimal die woche und dort arbeitet man
mit bestimmten puls also sie können auf
die website der universität dortmund
gehen
wir brauchen ja solche modelle die
werden dann ausgetestet und hoffen wir
dass sie funktionieren
ich kann aber eben nur folgendes sagen
diese tests werden ebenso oder diese
strategien werden eben auch nur
funktionieren wenn die instanzen nicht
zu hoch sind wenn die instanzen zu hoch
sind dann werden dort zu viele positive
testergebnisse erscheinen und dann muss
man leider das konzept wieder runter
fahren das heißt also bei all diesen
konzepten wo immer wir sind die
grundvoraussetzung für öffnungen ist die
niedrige incident und die müssen wir
erstmal kriegen wir sehen ja gerade
genau das gegenteil wir sind ja mitten
in dieser dritten welle das heißt also
wo ich glücklich wäre bei der ganzen
berichterstattung wenn sie immer sehen
dass es bestimmte rahmenbedingungen gibt
unter denen man die dann ausprobieren
kann
und wenn man zum beispiel wird auch nach
typ in den schauen auch dort gehen die
instanzen weit über um
inzwischen das heißt also auch dort ist
das test von ca
das festkonzert läuft noch dort in
bestimmten lebens werden aber wenn die
instanzen weiter steigen
dann wird auch das natürlich kritisch
beäugt das heißt also mit tests können
wir das virus nicht weg testen sondern
wir können konzepte schützen aber wenn
die inzidenz zu hoch kommt dann müssen
wir leider wieder schließen das heißt
also die erste aufgabe ist die inzidenz
runterzubringen es gibt nur gründe für
den niedrigen sident leben retten
infektion verhindern und auch eben
lebenswelten wieder öffnen können das
geht nur bei niedriger inzidenz die zum
thema belastbarkeit von zahlen habe ich
jetzt mehrere fragen unter anderem von
theo geers vom deutschlandfunk der
wissen möchte warum es im 1300 der
pandemie bis jetzt das rk ii und die
gesundheitsämter nicht schaffen
kontinuierlich das heißt auch an
wochenenden und an feiertagen belastbare
infektionszahlen zu ermitteln
ich will nur eins hinzufügen es geht
nicht nur und dann können wir zur
meldung sagen aber es ist wichtig zu
sehen es geht ja nicht nur um die
gesundheitsämter in einer zeit wurden
gesundheitswesen auch in arztpraxen zum
beispiel weniger geöffnet ist können
weniger test stattfinden und ein
gesundheitsamt kann nur das melden was
getestet worden ist das ist ein faktor
der auch dazu kommt deswegen ist mir
sehr wichtig das ist nämlich auch nicht
fair gegenüber den kolleginnen und
kollegen in den gesundheitsämtern die
auch am wochenende und am feiertag sehr
häufig arbeiten zur kenntnis zu nehmen
dass das jetzt irgendwie nicht nur was
mit meldeverhalten zu tun hat sondern
schlicht und ergreifend mit dem umstand
dass in einem gesundheitssystem das an
feiertagen auch in arztpraxen zb
runterfährt weniger test stattfinden ja
ich kann da nicht viel mehr zu ergänzen
wenn bestimmte teile des öffentlichen
lebens runter gefahren sind wie das in
den ferien der fall ist wenn dann zum
beispiel arztpraxen auch schließen dann
ist das der effekt das heißt also man
kann die zahlen der nicht erfinden
sondern man bekommt die zahlen die man
geliefert bekommt aber der entscheidende
punkt ist auch der und darum ist die
diskussion wirklich nicht immer
hilfreich
wir haben genug andere informationen und
wenn wir wissen dass die dritte welle da
ist wenn wir wissen dass wir einem
exponentiellen wachstum sind dann kann
es doch nicht
dass man sich durch einige niedrige
zahlen über einige tage irritieren lässt
sondern wir sehen ja dass die zahl
wachsen und ich will das noch mal sagen
der einzige wirkliche echtzeit indikator
den wir haben und da bin ich sehr
dankbar für das war das glaube ich im
april letzten jahres gesetzlich geregelt
haben das intensivbetten register
da braucht man jetzt nicht drumherum zu
reden oder zu diskutieren
dort liegen menschen auf
intensivstationen und von denen die
invasiv beatmet werden sterben nach den
zahlen über vom letzten jahr kennen etwa
jeder zweite und die sind dort und die
sind positiv getestet und sie
reflektieren ein geschehen das etwa ein
zwei wochen vorher geschehen ist das ist
so also bitte lassen sie uns die
interessanten und wichtigen zahlen nicht
aus dem auge lassen
dankeschön zum ersten ergänzen kann
ich versuche das hier so ein bisschen zu
straffen der der auch sich und nach
diesem test und impfangebot in den
unternehmen erkundigt und fragt wie
wichtig dass in den betrieben sei für
die pandemie bekämpfung als zum ersten
die kollegen im wirtschafts- und dem
arbeitsministerium werden ja gerade
entsprechende umfragen und zahlen und
rückmeldungen aus bei denen ja auch
sozusagen persönlich empirisch zu sehen
ist dass das testangebot deutlich
ausgeweitet ist aber noch nicht die
zielmarke ist ja idealerweise über 90
prozent der unternehmen so ist es auch
in der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
als wir die testangebote in den
unternehmen adressiert haben die
selbstverpflichtung der wirtschaft
besprochen worden
er ist nur eines wichtig dabei das eine
ist die frage wie verbindlich bieten
unternehmen das an
es ist aber mindestens genauso wichtig
wenn ich noch wichtiger wie sehr
integrieren die beschäftigten das in
ihren arbeitsalltag weil wir sehen einen
ganz vielen stellen wir haben die
erfahrung aus den test angeboten für die
lehrerinnen und lehrer aus herbst
letzten jahres schon da haben wir 20 bis
30 prozent etwa plus/minus das angebot
auch regelmäßig benutzt und das wichtige
ist sozusagen einerseits dass das
angebot da ist im betrieblichen alltag
aber es ist genauso wichtig dass es dann
auch genutzt wird und was wir bisher
sehen aus den erfahrungen ist dass dass
er diese größenordnung 20 bis 40 prozent
hat auch in unternehmen die das sehr
großzügig anbieten
bei den beschäftigten die annahme und
deswegen sind beide seiten wichtig wir
wollen über 90 prozent der unternehmen
idealerweise gern 100 die entsprechend
für ihre nicht im home-office
befindlichen beschäftigten mindestens
zweimal pro woche ein entsprechendes
testangebot möglich machen schnell oder
selbst ist aber gleichzeitig ist es dann
genauso wichtig dass die beschäftigten
das für sich in den wöchentlichen
berufsalltag integrieren dass man im
zweifel eine feste zeit hat zu der man
sich eben testen ist die meinen für
quasi als als maßzahl die uns quasi die
dunkelste vorfahren hat sozusagen
diesbezüglich hat es einen wert keine
frage aber ich möchte es noch mal ganz
klar sagen also wir können das virus
nicht weg testen was wir mit diesen test
strategien erreichen ist dass man etwas
früher den einen oder die andere
erkennen wird die infiziert ist und
dadurch kann man das infektionsgeschehen
dann natürlich dort schneller reduzieren
das ist sehr sehr wichtig dann wenn das
funktioniert das geht aber nur wenn die
tests eben in einer bestimmten frequenz
sind aber unabhängig von den tests sind
die ganzen anderen maßnahmen das
entscheidende ja das heißt also die
schutzmaßnahmen die präventionsmaßnahmen
sind das wichtige und ich sage es
nochmal wenn die inzidenz hochgeht dann
werden so viele menschen positiv
getestet werden dass sie die betriebe
dann wieder schließen müssen das heißt
also sie erkennen dass ein wenig früher
aber die dunkelziffer wird nicht
maßgeblich durch diese tests beeinflusst
denn es sind ja in der regel auch
schnelltests bzw teilweise selbsttests
die er nicht die gleiche qualität haben
wie das bei pcr test der fall ist sie
sind ein werkzeug ein layer obendrauf
aber sie ersetzen kein von den anderen
gegen den fahrer ist also zuerst einmal
liegen im beim bund keine dosen und
schon garnicht millionen ordnung
unbenutzt herum sondern wir haben
jenseits dessen was wir für etwa die
soldatinnen und soldaten die
bundespolizei zoll also die eigenen
beschäftigten die auch in der
entsprechenden priorisierung gruppe sind
keine das sind ja nur dann wenige 10
zehntausende größenordnung um die es
geht keine lagerhaltung seitens des
bundes sondern es wird direkt
ausgeliefert an die länder oder
neuerdings jetzt eben über den
großhandel und die apotheken an die
arztpraxen was die planung angeht in den
ländern ist das ja was die impfzentren
angeblich steuerung der impfzentren die
die sind sehr effizient und ich also
jeden den ich kenne ich weiß nicht ob
sie andere berichte haben denn ein
impfzentrum geimpft wurde berichtet nur
bestes über die abläufe über die
gesamtstimmung über das was da passiert
die impfzentren in sich sind sehr
effizient die frage ist die der planung
und die kann man halt nicht über nacht
machen wenn so etwas passiert wie mit
astra zenica dass wir binnen stunden zur
veränderten einschätzung gekommen sind
und erstmal sozusagen sonne sonne so
eine impf apparat stoppen muss sein tun
dann das wieder einzupendeln und dann
umzustellen auf über 60 jährige das
klingt alles so leicht das ist aber
natürlich weil es ja millionen menschen
betrifft oder hunderttausende die schon
termine haben dann schon was ein paar
tage dauert der umstand dass wir heute
erstmalig fast 400.000 oder gestern
heute morgen gemeldet
fast 400.000 impfungen in den
impfzentren erstmalig diese
größenordnung gesehen haben ist doch ein
indiz dafür dass es sich besser
einpendelt und wir müssen in dieser
größenordnung übrigen bleiben wenn die
länder 2,25 millionen dosen pro woche
für impfen sollen und wollen das ist ja
die größenordnung muss es pro tag
jedenfalls über 300.000 impfdosen geben
um das entsprechend umzusetzen und
deswegen hält jetzt niemand irgendwie
riesige lager und will die nicht in
impfungen bringen sondern wenn sie für
die nächsten zwei drei wochen im termin
haben sind zum teil dafür für diese
impftermine dann die impfdosen bereits
zurückgelegt das bleibt aber bei einem
prinzip das sehe ich ja wie viele andere
und die kolleginnen und kollegen den
ländern auch wir sollten
schnellstmöglich was an impfstoffen da
ist für impfen deswegen habe ich am 24
märz die länder gebeten die lagerhaltung
gängen null zu fahren
und gerade in dieser damals beginnenden
dritten welle so schnell als möglich so
viele menschen als möglich zu impfen vor
allem auch einen ersten schutz zu geben
ihre sehr dankbar wenn wir ein bisschen
schneller werden könnten weil ich noch
wirklich sehr viele fragen habe die
nächste ist bei der kollegin hier
[Musik]
also wir haben ja hier eine verordnung
gerade in abstimmung nicht richtig
gesehen hat vom ärzteblatt bereits
berichtet eine verordnung im abstimmung
die die frage der vergütung für die
ärztinnen und ärzte vor allem auch im
hausärztlichen bereich oder im notdienst
bereich regelt wie die weitere abfolge
das ist sehr sehr wichtig dass diese
antikörper medikamente sehr frühzeitig
gegeben werden die machen in der klinik
keinen sinn mehr die machen dann einen
sinn wenn bei einem ausbruch oder auch
in dem einzelfall ist ein risiko
einschätzung des behandelnden arztes
gibt die sagt das ist eine situation die
mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit einen
schwereren verlauf nach sich zieht
und wenn diese einschätzung des arztes
vorliegt können diese antikörper
medikamenten das ist das was wir
mittlerweile empirisch berichtet sehen
auch aus ausbruch situation in
pflegeeinrichtungen vor den impfungen
können diese antikörper gaben einen
echten unterschied machen und leben
retten und leid vermeiden
und aus diesen ersten erfahrungen ist
eben der verordnungsentwurf entstanden
der eine vergütung vorsieht eine
struktur vorsieht um tatsächlich in noch
viel mehr fällen
denn das ist das ziel neben dem impfen
natürlich auch durch etwa diese antike
beigabe die zahl der schweren verläufe
zu reduzieren
eine entsprechende behandlung möglich zu
machen frau kurz ich bin in dem thema
nicht so drin aber vermutet dass es sich
um dieselben antikörper halt und handelt
von frau kurz von der pharmazeutischen
zeitung fragt nach dem monoklonalen
antikörpern und möchte wissen wie viele
dosen bereits verabreicht wurden wo
unter welchen fällen über welchen
patienten
das müssten wir gegebenenfalls
nachliefern das kann ich so detailliert
nicht sagen am vw hat recht es ist im
moment noch eine also die zeit könnte
man deutlich steigern aus meiner sicht
sollte
auch in dieser phase der pandemie
gesteigert werden dafür ist es wichtig
dass die ärzte vor ort erster kenntnis
haben es gibt empfehlungen der
fachgesellschaften auch dazu und
zweitens wie eben und das machen wir
gerade er zügig noch mal zusätzlich
sicherheit geben bei der vergütung weil
das ist aufwendig ich will das noch mal
sagen die antikörper gabe das ist ja
kein keine tablette sondern das ist
infusionen
das dauert 2 34 stunden der patient muss
beobachtet werden idealerweise dabei
also ist aufwändig und das hat er
natürlich auch eine vergütung suspect
jung hat die nächste frage möglich
zum ersten was mobilität runterfahren
angeht zum beispiel da wo es eben geht
den weg zur arbeit zu sparen indem rom
auf was gemacht wird da wo's guet klaren
pflegekraft ein polizist kann in aller
regel nicht home office machen und viele
andere auch nicht aber viele können und
in den bereichen würde der weg zur
arbeit wegfallen und der rückweg auch
und mobilität reduzieren wenn das viele
machen im ganzen land ein anderes thema
ist es ja auch eine empfehlung vom bund
und ländern auf nicht notwendige reisen
insbesondere auch touristische reisen zu
verzichten so schwer das feld weil es
natürlich das ist das leben lebenswert
macht aber in dieser phase der pandemie
wie über ostern das ja auch nach meiner
wahrnehmung viele gemacht haben statt
des eigentlich geplanten familienbesuche
daneben die reise zum familientreffen
und das familientreffen als solches
nicht stattfinden zu lassen das ist
mobilität runterfahren und reduzieren
und was die lage angeht erinnert mich
das gerade alles streckenweise ein wenig
an die situation im letzten oktober
und die ist uns allen nicht gut bekommen
und ich kann das nur was sie gesagt
haben letzte woche die einschätzung ist
natürlich immer noch so über ostern hat
haben wir indikationen anhand von
mobilität dass dort wirklich insgesamt
weniger mobilität war also diese
osterferien haben die menschen klug
genutzt
aber wenn wir nicht in einen lock down
gehen das heißt wenn wir die mobilität
nicht stärker einschränken werden wir
entsprechende modellierungen auch
publiziert im epidemiologischen projekte
unter anderem dann werden eben die
zahlen steigen und dann werden wir eben
auch viele menschen ihr leben verlieren
in unserem land also der in für den
infektionsschutz gegen kuwait 19
ist diese situation nicht zuträglich das
ist offensichtlich dass wissen wir das
ist allgemeines wissen und da muss man
auch nichts darüber diskutieren oder
schönreden oder schlecht drehen
jeder jeder tag den wir später handeln
verlieren wir menschen leben ganz klar
markus grill von ndr wdr bittet ob sie
noch mal konkret ausführen könnten
welche maßnahmen zu einem erfolgreichen
lockdown gehören was also außer den
jetzt bereits stehenden maßnahmen hinzu
kommen soll und wie lange soll dieser
von ihnen nötig gehalten lockdown dauern
wenn wir die modellierung anschaut die
von vielen gruppen aus deutschland
kommen dann heißt ein locker und dass
die mobilität massiv eingeschränkt wird
ich wie viele von den besteht ziehen sie
auf die daten aus dem letzten frühjahr
wo wir eine starke einschränkung der
bewegungsfreiheit gehabt hatte und
meisten modellierer sprechen von
zeiträumen zwischen zwei und vier wochen
die das gehalten werden müsste damit man
diese welle brechen kann
das sind daten die wir aus
modellierungen können
die nächste frage ist bei ihnen
[Musik]
also zuerst ich habe gerade eben gesagt
wir sollten die pandemie fragen nicht
mit parteipolitischen fragen vermengen
und ich habe nicht vor meine
bundespressekonferenz zur pandemie mit
parteipolitischen fragen zu vermengen
ausdrücklich nicht
was die frage angeht eines möglichen
bundesgesetzes ist das ja das was ich
gerade gesagt habe wenn wir im moment
die situation haben und man übrigens
ausdrücklich nicht die
ministerpräsidenten der beiden von ihnen
genannten länder sondern eher die
wortmeldungen der letzten stunden
wenn es eine einschätzung der lage gibt
die offensichtlich anders ist
ich habe die umstände nicht erkannt
werden die ist notwendig machen
maßnahmen zu ergreifen
dann ist das ja erst mal was wir zur
kenntnis nehmen müssen und gleichzeitig
braucht uns aus unserer sicht maßnahmen
und das ist eben das was wir ja in der
bundesregierung mit dem bundestag mit
bundesländern nicht mein sowohl
ministerpräsident sowie
ministerpräsident laschet haben ja
gesagt im zweifel dann eine
bundesgesetzliche regelung auch
diskutieren und die details besprechen
wir jetzt erst einmal in der
bundesregierung am ende als rasieren sie
aber dieselben themen natürlich die wir
gerade als notwendige maßnahmen
besprochen haben vor allem bei einer
instanz die über die ja mit den ländern
vereinbarten notbremse liegt das ist ja
dass wir haben ja eigentlich alle
mechanismen vereinbart
aber wenn sie ebenso zusagen nicht zur
anwendung kommen dann ist natürlich eine
bundesgesetzliche regelung eine
möglichkeit das zu machen
über bundesgesetze entscheidet aber
tatsächlich ja nicht die bundesregierung
sondern deutsche bundestag
und deswegen sehen sie mir nach wenn es
jetzt natürlich einfach in den nächsten
stunden und tagen auch abstimmungen
[Musik]
im moment ist es ja so dass nach dem
infektionsschutzgesetz der bund gar
keine beschränkenden massnahmen im
inland
von ihm kann nach gesetzlicher grundlage
wir können die einreise fragen regeln
wie ansonsten natürlich der bund
generell für einreisen zuständig ist
aber alles was beschränkende maßnahmen
angeht gastronomie einzelhandel kontakt
beschränkungen sind ausschließlich nach
aktueller rechtslage
infektionsschutzgesetz maßnahmen der
behörden in den ländern oder in den
kommunen und die debatte ist ja ob es
einen mechanismus geben soll wo bei
einer bestimmten instruments
bundeseinheitlich bundesgesetzlich
maßnahmen vorgesehen sind die in zweifel
denjenigen engeln die bei der notbremse
auch vereinbart war
dazu gibt es zwei konkrete fragen zum
infektionsschutzgesetz von anja meyer
von weser-kurier und von jan drebes von
der rheinischen post die nämlich seele
minister fragen ob sie für eine
verschärfung respektive änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes sind wenn ja in
welcher tiefe und ob es einen stufenplan
für die vorschriften mit den ländern
geben soll
also zuerst einmal geändert würde
zuerst einmal ist mir ist mir eins
wichtig dass nämlich was er professor
wieder gerade gesagt hat ich finde wir
diskutieren hier seit tagen über das wie
das was wäre eigentlich und das wandern
vor allem wer aber eigentlich viel
wichtiger sollten maßnahmen ergreifen
stattdessen wird intensiv über sie
diskutiert das ist eine wichtige frage
nicht selten im leben ist das wie eine
wichtige frage aber es ist in diesem
fall nicht die entscheidende frage und
die entscheidende frage ist und ich wir
haben ja die bereiche genannt private
kontakte kita schule
es macht jetzt keinen sinn beim
einzelnen irgendwie noch das ist ja
nicht der bereich um dienstleiter geht
geht um private kontakte kita schule
betrieblichen alltag dort eben zu
entsprechenden vereinbarungen nicht nur
vereinbarung wir haben vereinbarung zu
maßnahmen zu kommen und eine
bundesgesetzliche regelung braucht geht
ja nicht in 24 stunden wird ihre die
wird nicht am montag vereinbart seien
abschliessend weil gesetzgebung selbst
wenn sie schnell geht ein paar tage
gebraucht und ich wäre im zweifel immer
für die schnellstmögliche variante weil
wie gesagt nicht vieles gerade an die
situation im oktober erinnert gleichwohl
wenn das nicht geht ist eine änderung
des infektionsschutzgesetzes eine
mögliche option
und das ist das was ich gerade gesagt
habe es wäre die option dass erstmalig
auf bundesebene nicht nur eine befugnis
an die länder und die kommunalen
behörden gegeben wird maßnahmen zu
ergreifen sondern maßnahmen auf
bundesebene bestimmten parametern
folgend wie etwa der frage wie sie in
der notbremse definiert sind dann auch
ergriffen werden und das kann könnte man
natürlich im infektionsschutzgesetz
entsprechend regeln das wäre eine
fundamentale änderung weil erstmalig wie
gesagt auf bundesebene maßnahmen konkret
gemacht würden was beschränkungen von
kontakten angeht
aber es ist natürlich angesichts der
aktuellen lage eine zu diskutierende und
unbedingt zu diskutieren neue optionen
ich habe wirklich noch einige fragen das
hatte ich noch mal ein bisschen
geschwindigkeit
wobei die eigentliche grund dafür waren
unter anderem schiffe oder andere
objekte und jeden anstand bürger
eingestellt haben machen wir haben hier
so die regel eine frage und um einen
artgenossen entschuldigung für vor ende
zum ersten was die frage angeht der
mengen muss es andersrum aufziehen
sowieso ist die logik ob sie einem
gefällt oder nicht aber so ist die
vereinbarte logik zwischen bund und
ländern ministerpräsidenten beschluss
das nehme ich die impfzentren plus minus
2,25 millionen dosen pro woche für die
impfzentren und zur weiteren vernetzung
den impfzentren sozusagen als grundlast
wenn ich dieses wort kennen darf
bekommen und dort eben weiter und in den
impfzentren passiert es ja auch sehr
effizient also ich bin noch mal sagen
die abläufe in den im center sind ja gut
eingespielte abläufe
entscheidend ist ja er immer wieder die
frage des weges dorthin und der
terminvereinbarung aber jedenfalls 2,25
millionen dosen pro woche in den
impfzentren verimpft werden das heißt im
umkehrschluss dass alles was darüber
hinaus geht jetzt in die arztpraxen geht
und gehen kann
das waren in dieser woche 940.000 in der
nächste woche eine million und ich würde
liebend gerne auch noch mehr impfdosen
auch in der darauf folgenden woche in
die arztpraxen geben
ich kann aber tatsächlich nur die
impfdosen versenden sozusagen und zur
verfügung stellen
die tatsächlich auch da sind und wir
haben immer gesagt dass es in der
kalenderwoche 16 erstmalig dann bei
unter- und astrazeneca in
praxen gibt ich weiß nicht wer mit mehr
biontech also wir haben immer gesagt die
zahlen sind immer vorläufige ich
verstehe das total
deswegen hat die kassenärztliche
bundesvereinigung übrigens in ihrem
rundschreiben an die ärzte letzte woche
auch gesagt das halt bei der
terminplanung sehr viel flexibilität
wird notwendig sein müssen weil wir
können den arztpraxen jetzt noch nicht
sagen wie viele dosen sie in zwei wochen
als die einzelne praxis weiß jetzt noch
nicht wie viele dosen sie in zwei wochen
bekommt das ist im moment noch so und
deswegen ist terminvereinbarung im
moment schwierig und deswegen kann ich
die patientinnen und patienten übrigens
auch nur nochmals bitten zur entlastung
der eigenen hausärzte nicht aktiv
anrufen im moment sondern es ist
vereinbart dass die ärztinnen und ärzte
aus ihren patientinnen und patienten
auch einfach schauen wer ist jetzt
sozusagen wegen der vorerkrankung und
der lebenssituation pflegebedürftig zu
hause in der situation jetzt die impfung
auch in dieser woche als erstes bekommen
zu wollen
es macht ja sonst die arztpraxen und die
arzthelferin und alle beteiligten sehr
sehr schwer wenn jetzt alle anrufen also
im moment ist es noch so dass die ärzte
einladen und das manchmal sich
kurzfristig ändert das ist nicht der
idealzustand das weiß ich aber die
andersrum zeigt einfach der erfolg
dieser woche die erste sind sehr schnell
und sehr flexibel und ich meine
innerhalb von zwei tagen haben die jetzt
600.000 menschen geimpft die werden
innerhalb einer woche jetzt ein prozent
der deutschen impfen die werden nächste
woche ein prozent der deutschen impfen
sie wenn übernächste woche ein prozent
der deutschen impfen und in der woche
drauf schon zwei prozent das heißt also
die arztpraxen zusätzlich dazu zu nehmen
macht einen echten unterschied frage wie
schnell das infektionsschutzgesetz gehen
kann ist am ende eine frage an den
deutschen bundestag es gibt ja fristen
und es gibt frist hat sich möglichkeiten
und frisst verzicht geht nur wenn alle
oder viele der fraktionen sich
beteiligen das kann ich ihnen die
abläufe im bundestag dass wir am ende
auch organisationsleiter des bundestages
ist nicht sagen aber wir haben ja schon
krisensituationen erlebt in dem
bundesgesetze sehr schnell gehen konnten
binnen weniger tage braucht auch eine
gesetzliche grundlage
wir gehen das hirn bisherigen
nachspielzeit ich
das schaffen wir jetzt noch berater
patinex gefragt die frage das hat der
professor will ja gerade schon gesagt
ist nicht die zahl der betten betten und
auch im zweifel bergungsgerät haben wir
auch noch vorrätig haben wir genug
das thema ist das personal und jeden
wissen sie alle umfragen zeigen den
deutschen ist die frage wie wir das
pflegepersonal welche rahmenbedingungen
wir ihnen geben sehr sehr wichtig wir
entscheiden aber gerade alle miteinander
jeden tag durch unser eigenes verhalten
die rahmenbedingungen der pflegekräfte
in den krankenhäusern ziemlich sehr und
1 übrigens sehr wichtig wir schauen
immer auf die intensivstation wir haben
so viele kurven 19 patienten in den
nicht intensiv bereichen in den kliniken
wie auch schon lange nicht mehr und auch
in diesen bereichen die müssen ja
isoliert werden weil infektion ist
möglicherweise das ist richtig aufwendig
nicht nur auf der intensivstation
sondern auch in den anderen stationen
der krankenhäuser und das ist gerade
alles eine enorme belastung für das
pflegepersonal die ärztinnen und ärzte
übrigens die reinigungskräfte alle seit
monaten und intensivpflege kräfte
ausbilden geht nicht in sechs monaten
das wird auch das verfassungsrecht der
konzern fünf gesetze ändern
die müssen ja gut ausgebildet seien
nicht ändern wir haben so viel intensiv
mit lege kräfte wie wenige andere länder
auf der welt wir haben kapazitäten wie
wenige andere länder auf der welt aber
wir haben sie nicht unendlich und jedem
der daran gelegen ist dass wir unsere
intensiv pflegekräfte nicht so
verschleißen das übrigens anschließend
viele sagen ich mach das jetzt hier noch
einmal mit aber dann
ach bin ich weg das ist nämlich eine
stimmung die da gerade entsteht dass wir
dann nach dieser pandemie erst recht
probleme haben in den intensivstationen
beim personal
während daran gelegen ist dass das nicht
passiert dem sollte auch daran gelegen
sein dass wir die zahl der kurve 19
intensivpatienten und klinischen
patienten unterbringen
reitschuster eine intensivpflege
ausbildung braucht 23 jahre dass eine
fachausbildung zusätzlich zur pflege
fachausbildung die kann man nicht in
zwölf monaten mal eben erhöhen sind
viele zusätzlich geschult worden um im
fall der fälle einspringen zu können das
ist ja hat er schon stattgefunden über
den sommer in ganz vielen kliniken
man wird zusätzlich notbehelf situation
schaffen können das ist dann aber keine
optimale behandlung mehr maßnahmen um
notbehelf und pläne zu entwickeln die
gibt's die gibt's seit letztem frühjahr
und sommer ist alles entwickelt worden
die frage ist nur ich verstehen manchmal
die logik dahinter nicht wollen wir
warten bis 10.000 also was ist in die
logik das wollen wir warten bis wollen
wir die grenze austesten wollen was
einmal austesten was das land kann in
einer notsituation in der
intensivstation
was sollen das für ein gedankengang sein
das sind 15 15.000 möglicherweise mehr
kurbelt 19 patienten die leiden
familien die leiden jeder zweite
beatmete verstirbt
also wir sind jetzt in einer situation
weil das ja ein thema ist dass viele
können wir sind jetzt gerade in einer
phase also ich hab das glaube ich schon
mal so gesagt ich habe wurde mir wurde
dann gesagt nicht kilometer 38 beim
marathon ist der schwierigste sondern 33
34 wo immer wir sehen gerade in einer
phase wo das ziel ja nicht irgendwie
pfeifen im walde ist also wird das ist
ja nicht ist ja nicht unendlich weg
deswegen ist der begriff der brücke ja
durchaus richtig sondern dass wir jedem
in deutschland impfen können den zustand
werden wir nach allem was wir heute an
lieferzusagen
und sicherheit haben im sommer erreichen
der sommer ist noch ein quartal weg da
geht dann ein bisschen länger dass wir
nicht gleich anfang juli alles sein aber
im sommer
es geht jetzt hier gerade noch mal um
einige wochen monate miteinander
die überlastung die wir jetzt zwölf
monate lang erfolgreich vermieden haben
zu vermeiden und ja ich bin genauso leid
wie alle anderen auch ich will da auch
raus und ich will auch wieder alltag und
ich will auch wieder feiern und ich will
auch wieder gastronomie und einkaufen
aber so kurz wer hätte gedacht vor sechs
monaten dass wir überhaupt ein impfstoff
waren zu kurz vor erreichen eines
umfassenden impfens der bevölkerung
jetzt zu sagen na dann lassen wir es
halt passieren ist für ihn jedenfalls
keine politik die ich vernünftig finden
kann
sie haben das wort
[Musik]
zuerst einmal wäre es schon ein wert an
sich wenn die vereinbarte maßnahmen
nämlich die notbremse bei hunderter
incidents konsequent umgesetzt würde was
heißt dass begonnen eröffnung schritte
zurück zu nehmen es genau beschrieben
welche öffnungen dann zurück zu nehmen
sind zusätzliche beschränkungen und in
dem text stehen ausgangs beschränkungen
ist die frage von kitas und schulen
adressiert die frage wo masken zu tragen
sind medizinische schutzmasken
adressiert im grunde ist sozusagen der
instrumentenkasten im
ministerpräsidenten beschluss bodtländer
beschluss von anfang märz vollumfänglich
beschrieben dann bist du nur angewandt
werden
angesichts der entwicklung die wir haben
und der steigenden zahl von landkreisen
und kreisfreien städten die auch über
100 geht und die belastung der
intensivstation haben wäre aus meiner
sicht ein das habe ich ja auch übrigens
hier schon gesagt einmal für eine zeit
zwei drei wochen alles runter fahren
aber es ist alles so wie wir bis jetzt
auch etwa letztes ostern runterfahren
gemacht haben situation letztes ostern
über dieses ostern für zwei drei wochen
das wäre perfekt gewesen
die osterzeit wir auch perfekt gewesen
bei schulen geschlossen waren
das ist einfach mit einer gemeinsamen
kraftanstrengung zu verbinden die zahlen
bundesweit idealer weise spürbar unter
100 zu drücken und dann test gestützt
außengastronomie einzelhandel all die
bereiche wieder zu öffnen wo wir uns
alle eine perspektive wünschen und der
unterschied zu vor zwölf monaten es war
ja viele sagen es ist das gleiche wie
vor zwölf monaten
der unterschied ist wir können diesmal
eine test gestützte öffnungs perspektive
geben und mit dem impfen noch mal eine
ganz andere perspektive auf dem weg raus
da wird es noch eine frage zu
modellprojekten von tobias schulze von
der taz werden diese projekte ihrer
meinung nach ausreichend
wissenschaftlich begleitet bzw evaluiert
herr professor wieder ist das rk ii
daran in irgendeiner form beteiligt es
gibt eine reihe von modellprojekten
natürlich kann das rk ii nicht überall
beteiligt seien aber die meisten die mir
bekannt sind sind wissenschaftlich
begleitet ja und meistens auch natürlich
von universitäten
aber es gibt eine reihe von modellbauer
ich möchte noch mal folgendes sagen alle
modellierung die wir kennen sagen ganz
klar ein wirklich richtig hartes
runterfahren für eine gewisse zeit
bringt die zahl so weit runter dass man
dann danach mit den tunnel
modellprojekten die dann ins leben
kommen eben wieder gezielt öffnen kann
das ist deutlich effizienter als monate
lang einen soft lock down zu haben das
sagen alle modellierungen alle
wissenschaftler und das ist insofern 1 1
ein bekanntes wissen und darum brauchen
wir diese modellprojekte um dann nachdem
wir die zahlen gebrochen habe
untergebracht haben wieder zu öffnen und
die modellprojekt sind gut und wichtig
ist sollte sich auch keiner demotivieren
lassen die modellprojekt zu haben denn
es kommt ja die zeit dann wenn wir unten
sind und dann brauchen wir ja das
öffentliche leben hochzufahren
dafür brauchen wir aber diese struktur
insofern bin ich davon überzeugt dass
die modellprojekte in deutschland gut
gemacht wenn ob es genügend sind das
vermag ich nicht zu sagen jetzt habe
hier vor allem eine frage
[Musik]
hier gibt es auch mehrere fragen dazu ob
der vertrag schon kurz vor der
unterzeichnung steht unter anderem also
zuerst einmal gibt es eine reihe von
impfstoff angeboten wo es keine eu
vertrag gibt auf der welt
insgesamt haben wir für die europäische
union für diese phase mir sehr wichtig
übrigens dass die kommission uns jetzt
sehr zeitnah mal darlegt wie denn für
2022 impfstoffe gesichert werden für die
möglichkeit für die notwendigkeit einer
booster impfung die kann ja kommen dass
wir eine dritte impfung brauchen oder
auch möglicherweise wenn mutationen
entstehen das eine zusätzliche impfung
brauchen und ich möchte dass wir jetzt
im frühjahr wissen was wir für 2022
sichern damit wir jetzt dann auch was
produktionskapazitäten und anderes
angeht
die dinge so sichern dass wir nächstes
mal noch schneller impfen können der
teil der zweite teil ist das jetzt
erstmal eine entscheidung das hat sich
ja auch damit zu tun dass einige
eu-staaten ja schon auch gehandelt haben
in unterschiedlichen facetten und
anderes mehr ansonsten müssen sie die
frage auch bitte dann nach brüssel
berichten
unabhängig davon ist für uns doch jetzt
erst mal entscheidend eines zwei dinge
erstens eine zulassung finden es geht
ein bisschen in den debatten immer unter
als manchmal klingt das so als müssten
wir sputnik 505 1.50 kaufen und dann
könnten wir es einsetzen dass er nicht
das thema wir brauchen eine zulassung
die zulassung scheitert nicht daran dass
die behörden so langsam sind das
paul-ehrlich-institut also unsere
behörde ist ihr haupt rapport er im
europäischen verfahren also
berichterstatter dafür sondern wir
können nur zulassen wenn die daten da
sind und gerade nach den erfahrungen die
mit letzten wochen gemacht haben bestehe
ich auch auf eine zulassung bei der
europäischen arzneimittelagentur bevor
wir anfangen ein impfstoff zu verkaufen
dann meistens sehr gesunde im übrigen
und deswegen braucht es die zulassung
dafür braucht's daten und umso schneller
derjenige der russische antragsteller
die daten liefert desto schneller die
zulassung es wird bei den
zulassungsverfahren keine schuldhafte
oder unschuld haft oder irgendwie sonst
verzögerungen durch die behörden geben
sobald die daten da sind wenn sie
schnellstmöglich ausgewertet und zu
einer zulassungsentscheidung geführt
dass der eine teil der andere teil ist
dann die frage der verfügbarkeit und
auch da kriegen wir übrigens sehr viele
zwischenhändler angebote gerade bei
sputnik auch wir machen den vertrag wenn
dann natürlich direkt wie wir ihn auch
mit anderen herstellern machen direkt
und dort finden gerade zu diesen stunden
sozusagen und in diesen tagen nach der
entscheidung vorgestern dass wir das
national jetzt in vertragsbeziehungen
bringen finden statt und die
entscheidende frage für mich ist
tatsächlich gibt es was im zweiten
quartal
weil da macht es und für die jetzige
phase für diese impfkampagne noch ein
unterschied im zweiten quartal natürlich
richtig ein unterschied wenn und die
voraussetzung ist zulassung und mengen
verfügbar
und wir können den vertrag wie alle
anderen verträge auch abschließen unter
der bedingung der zulassung kaufen wir
das ist ja verträge die wir jetzt auch
abgeschlossen ob die zulassung klappt
oder nicht ist ja nicht in unseren
händen da sind wir davon abhängig dass
die daten geliefert werden
die vertragsverhandlungen findet gerade
statt das kann aus meiner sicht
vergleichsweise schnell gehen weil die
bedingungen sind ja klar die sind
vergleichbar mit denen wir verträge die
wir schon haben und am ende muss jetzt
halt klar sein über welche mengen zu
welchen zeiten wir reden unter der
bedingung an der zulassung die schnelle
der zulassung beeinflusst wirklich nur
die russische seite selbst durch
lieferung der da vor die allerletzte
frage an herrn rinke geht habe ich noch
eine frage von außen nämlich zu der
frage wann die zweitimpfung wann sie
entscheiden wann die zweitimpfung für
die unter 60-jährigen ansteht die zuvor
mit astrazeneca geimpft worden sind aus
meiner sicht am nächsten ich muss jetzt
aufpassen gesundheitsministerkonferenz
ist dienstag oder mittwoch ich bin mir
nicht ganz sicher werden wir die nächste
dienst beim montag ein einziges die
montags weil montags eigentlich im pkw
wer sie jetzt die mitte nächster woche
sagen werde der nächsten jahre recherche
stark und finden heraus wenn die
gesundheitsministerkonferenz aber zu dem
zeitpunkt geben herr professor mehr und
deko wird dabei sein weil es einfach
nochmal informationsbedarf gibt aber ich
gehe grundsätzlich davon aus dass wir
natürlich die empfehlungen der ständigen
impfkommission dann auch zu grundlage
machen
danke herr inkl
[Musik]
ich kenne nur einen beschluss der
gesundheitsminister unter
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz der sagt
der bund beschafft vielen dank ich danke
allen für ihre ausdauer
durchhaltevermögen und dass wir das bin
froh dass wir hier alles wort kommen
lassen konnte alle geschafft wir haben
alle geschaffen
dankeschön